[Music]
[Applause]
carson palmer's weekly appearance during
the nfl season brought to you by our
friends our partners level select cbd
looking for next level relief visit
levelselectcbd.com
carson palmer three of his former teams
were in the playoffs bengals of course
advancing uh against your raiders and
now you have the arizona cardinals
tonight against the rams let's start
with the bengals what do you see with
joe burrow as a former quarterback
looking at a current quarterback
i think the thing that jumps out to me
most is just his calmness
and it's since you know since his first
start as a rookie he just has a certain
poise and calmness in the pocket that
can't be taught it can't be coached
it can't be worked on it can't be
improved you either have that and and
you only notice it when things break
down and there's chaos around him he
doesn't even from again that first start
as a rookie he doesn't freak out and
look to get rid of the ball and
potentially throw it into the opposing
team's hands he stays cool he stays calm
he throws it away when he's supposed to
he takes a sack when he's supposed to he
just doesn't make that big mistake of
that big turnover and that's been
consistent since we started watching him
play at lsu
and then you have jamar chase
and
i guess the benefits of having somebody
that
you're basically the same age as whereas
you know aaron has devonte adams like we
have separation in ages sometimes but
how much of a benefit is that or is it a
benefit that you have somebody who's
basically learning as you're learning
yeah and more importantly the the time
on task with each other i mean those
guys you can see it i mean joe's letting
the ball go before jamar is finished you
know breaking at the top of his route
the rhythm and timing of their natural
passing game together is spectacular it
looks like they've been doing it for a
while together and it's there's a reason
for that it's because they have been
doing it for a while together
the kansas city chiefs last night scored
five touchdowns in around 11 minutes of
game time
that's that's the chiefs that we're used
to seeing i mean the whole first half of
the season we did not see that we saw
every opposing team sit back and play
coverage and play in two deep shells
and force patrick to check the ball in
and we've been hearing about it all
season
and then you saw the transition and the
transgression of mahomes deciding okay i
can't always look for tyreek hill on a
deep over route and try to hit kelsey up
the scene and he got he's gotten better
it's developed his game we've seen
patrick mahomes develop more in this
year
than any other year of his career and
he there's been more development than
his mvp years than his super bowl years
prior he is developing more and
understanding taking what the defense
has given him
uh at this stage in his career and it's
been really fun to watch and then all of
a sudden you're seeing patrick mahomes
realize all those checkdowns i was
throwing and all those getting the ball
out of my hands quick throws now we saw
last night him getting the benefit of
taking those checkdowns which is the
defense sucks up and comes up and plays
those checkdowns and you saw him hitting
some of those deeper and more
intermediate routes last night
i normally don't want to encourage my
quarterback or hope that he runs more
but with josh allen it just feels like
he needs he needs to do that
um
and he runs differently than lamar
jackson does but but it's there's
something about that weapon
that i
as much as i worry because he does take
on contact like how do how can you run
that way
and have a
a prolonged career
well you don't want to take away from
his strength i mean that is that that
running ability opens up that buffalo
offense and it opens up the rest of his
game
and you do not want to take that away
from the guy he's built for it he's not
195 pounds he's all of 240 pounds 250
pounds where a lot of those guys that
are tackling him way less than him so
you know there's
you're right i mean there's something
too you don't want to put the franchise
at risk every time he takes off past the
line of scrimmage but at the same time
that's his game that's what got him here
that's what's got that that team this
far in the playoffs you don't want to
tell him hey hey we're paying you to
throw it we're not paying you to run it
you want to let him you know
you know maximize the strength of his
game but also be smart and to this point
he's been smart he's gotten down he
hasn't taken on hits we have seen him
hurdle guys and jump over guys you can't
take that away from you know you can't
tell a dog not to bite those things
naturally happen and
you know you don't want to see him rush
for 150 yards 15 out of 17 weeks but
you'd also don't want to tell you know
tell them whoa whoa whoa we're paying
you to throw the ball
yeah it's just such a weapon and
you know when you see him run then you
go oh my god that's why he runs because
it's not he doesn't
like run out of desperation it's like he
knows i'm a weapon
deal with me and not that that mattered
with new england i mean the way buffalo
played
i mean that doesn't happen to bill
belichick they they threw a buffalo
threw a perfect game on offense
yeah i mean we we don't see belichick
get blown out in the first quarter ever
especially against you know especially
when you talk about you know two
afc east teams i mean those teams know
each other inside and out bill belichick
has been drumming the buffalo bills for
the last 20 years but i'm not gonna lie
it is kind of fun to watch belichick you
know with his hood on with his face
cover up and seeing him down 21-3 early
i mean that was fun we don't get to see
that very often
well okay which loss do you think more
people enjoy the patriots or the cowboys
i think the patriots i mean the cowboys
we've kind of we're used to seeing an
early playoff exit um they haven't been
as dominant as the patriots the patriots
and belichick have just been so dominant
i think the entire country was happy to
see that other than the patriot fans
obviously i think most most the us was
happy to see belichick head home in the
first round all right explain the final
play for the cowboys that dak said they
they practice it
but do you practice it
the way you're supposed to and that is
making sure that official touches the
ball so you can you know uh spike it
that that right there is what goes
through every quarterback's head in the
two-minute drill can i take off and run
it can i complete this ball in bounds
because the the x factor in all of the
games is the referee whether
you as a team an organization
you know make the game close enough to
where a ref can screw it up for you and
make the bad call
or
you make the clock situation so close
that the ref can screw it up and knock
you out of the way and almost fumble the
ball i mean that's why
coaches harp all the time and you're
starting to see it over the last handful
of years when receivers and running
backs have the ball they are running the
ball
physically to the ref in a two minute
situation
gingerly handing it to the ref because
most refs are going to fumble it and
drop it and their hands are cold they're
not used to touching the ball but that's
that's the game right now i mean in a
two-minute situation
do we put the game in the refs hands
where the ref can make a call or throw a
flag and we could win or lose off of
that poor decision or right decision
and can dak take off and run and get the
ball clocked with enough time for one
play left i mean that at the end of the
day playing for bruce arians in arizona
he would always harp on it do not let a
ref screw this for us
the refs will screw this up one way or
another do not let them screw it up and
unfortunately that's what happened in
dallas okay the play itself got any
problem with the play that was drawn up
no because if it worked and there was
two seconds left on the clock it would
have been brilliant heads up and and
then everything you know had they thrown
a hail mary for the touchdown mccarthy
would have been this genius that had
been coming up with all these in-game
scenarios and practicing this and that
at the end of the day you know
it's probably not the right decision
it's something you can work on and it
works half the time it doesn't work the
other half just unfortunately what we
saw happen was it didn't work that half
of the time for the for the cowboys yeah
but i wonder about this that um when
you're practicing are do you practice
where the quarterback gives it back to
the center or do you give it to the
official in that moment
you've got to give it to the official
because the official has to spot the
ball the center cannot spot it
so again
you're putting yourself at the refs win
if the ref screws it up and fumbles it
and the ball bounces you know 10 or 15
more yards and then the opposing defense
if they're smart they'll probably kick
in another three or four yards and
hopefully not get a penalty for that but
i just think in this day and age you
cannot put the game in the refs hands
the game needs to be determined by the
players and putting putting yourself and
your team in that situation where you
then have to get up from the slide and
transfer the ball from your hands to the
ref to the center to the spot there's
too many logistics too many things that
can go wrong like we saw
talking to carson palmer former nfl
quarterback his weekly appearance
brought to you by levelselectcbd.com
any issues with jimmy garoppolo
no i mean i think um
i think it was really telling at the end
of the game when they on i think it was
third and eleven
they they motioned debo in the backfield
and on third and eleven handed the ball
off
to a receiver tells you all you need to
know about the confidence that kyle
shanahan has and jimmy garoppolo well
wait but you don't have any issues with
garoppolo
as far as you know i think jimmy's a
nice player i think he's a good player i
think the future of the san francisco
49ers is wearing number five standing on
the sidelines
um but you know
that the interception that jimmy threw
where he just you know that's a ball you
can't miss you can't be
outside the pocket with nobody around
you and throw the ball five feet over a
guy's head in the playoffs that's just
there's enough of those that have
happened that tell me
when i see kyle shanahan on third and 11
for the game hand the ball off to a
receiver
that's the amount of confidence he has
in jimmy g and he knows he's a good
enough coach and that team is well you
know
there's good enough players on defense
there's good enough players surrounding
jimmy on offense that he can get away
with it
but we can all see the future of the san
francisco 40 49ers and that's in trey
lance
handicapped cardinals rams tonight
what's it come down to
well i just think ever since deandre
hopkins has been on the sideline with a
knee injury everything's been different
um the first couple times
uh you know when when deandre's in the
lineup the the first time the the
cardinals played the rams
it wasn't even close the the cardinals
drum the rams
this time it's just different since
we've seen deandre
uh we have not seen that security
blanket we have not seen the same the
explosive offense that we're used to
seeing the cardinals are good enough on
defense they do have enough game
wreckers guys like chandler jones buddha
baker on defense to make a game changing
play um
but i'm not gonna lie i am concerned
about my cards i i don't like us without
deandre i have not seen enough
explosiveness on offense without deandre
and i'm i'm unfortunately uh i'm
unfortunately seeing the the rams going
to
go out and win this game and then
probably go to go to green bay next week
i think they go to tampa
i i think the winner goes to tampa that
niners are going to green bay
okay
even better um but yeah i just don't i
just don't see the fire power i don't
see
kyler has not been the same player he
has not
uh been as dominant he has not thrown
first to many yards they have not scored
as many points since deandre's been out
of the lineup and i don't know if they
can get past the rams tonight
playoff wins in the last 25 seasons
jake deloam five trent dilfer five mark
sanchez four brad johnson four colin
kaepernick four dallas cowboys three
out
ouch ouch you know i watched uh jerry
jones press conference after the game
and
i don't know what's going to happen with
mccarthy i mean this
he said it after the game this is one of
the most
depressing losses that he's seen his
cowboys have and as long as he can
remember we all know he's quick with the
trigger on on coaches we all know he
always thinks the grass is greener with
another coach
he said it i mean when the owner comes
out and says we've got great players
we've got a great talent of pool of
players here that is a direct finger
point right between the eyes of the head
coach so i think these next 48 72 hours
is going to be interesting to see what
happens in in dallas but if you're dak
do you have to go to bat for your head
coach
i think so i mean dak had a successful
year dak played well dak put up great
numbers
and mccarthy's an offensive guy and and
i know kellen moore is calling the plays
but everything is flowing through game
plan wise through mccarthy so you know i
think i think you'll see dak that's the
type of player he is that's the type of
teammate he is he's always had his
coaches back i think i think dak will
have some nice things to say about
mccarthy but at the end of the day
there's one guy making choices in dallas
and that's jerry jones
thank you carson we'll talk to you next
week
thanks dan that's carson palmer brought
to you by the cbd trusted by
professional athletes level select cbd
provides targeted relief helps treat
everyday discomfort when you need it the
most level select cbd.com promo code
dp30 that will give you 30 off your
entire order not available in idaho iowa
and south dakota